hey dr. Burke here in this video we're
going to talk about cramps charley
horses if you have these here are the
causes there's four main causes the
number one cause of cramps in the
especially when you're sleeping at night
is medication the side effects of high
blood pressure medication also high
cholesterol medication and also
prednisone
so that will majorly affect the
contraction relaxation of your muscles
especially at night so that's number one
number two too much calcium calcium
causes the contraction of muscles now
that usually comes because your stomach
is off if you have a lot of acid reflux
or digestive problems that means you
don't have enough acid and the calcium
doesn't get mobilized and so that's your
going to end up having too much calcium
stuck in the joints and all that
another cause would be taking like too
many calcium supplements that are
calcium carbonate that's like rocks
you're going to plug up things let's say
you want to prevent osteoporosis you're
going to get a lot of crafts because
you're taking too much calcium so
calcium you know it could be you're
taking too much vitamin D without
divided the the other fats like vitamin
k2 and also the omega-3 fatty acids but
too much calcium because calcium always
works with other minerals and it could
be too you don't have the magnesium to
transport and to relate to calcium so
you always want to take these minerals
together especially calcium magnesium so
too much calcium will cause it and then
and the reason to bring it up is because
if you have a cramp and you just take
straight calcium it might make it worse
number three to little magnesium
magnesium is the relaxation mineral of
the muscle and that's the one that you
really want to take if you have cramps
so that will just knock it out like that
you could also take calcium magnesium
that would be good especially if it's in
a 1 to 1 ratio because that's what we
need and the fourth cause is too little
potassium and because potassium also is
involved in muscle contraction and that
would come from not eating enough
vegetables
or a lot of stress that can deplete the
potassium I don't know if you knew this
but our bodies need about 4700
milligrams of potassium every single day
yeah that's like seven to ten cups of
vegetables every single day like no
one's getting that so no wonder they're
deficient potassium and also if you add
on stress that will deeply deplete
potassium and if you also add in the
fact that sugar depletes potassium no
wonder the people have a lot of cramps
magnesium comes from the leafy green so
again if you have those vegetables
you're going to actually kill two birds
with one stone but I'm not saying never
have calcium like you should have some
good cheese from maybe a European cheese
or grass-fed cheese or some dairy like
kefir or maybe even yogurt that would be
a good source of calcium versus just
taking pills all the time but you just
want to look at these as a potential
cause of your cramps the other thing is
them if you're if you take apple cider
vinegar you'll make the body a little
more acidic and you'll really mobilize
this calcium into the tissues so that
episode of enter vinegar is really good
for cramps because it acidifies and it
transports a lot of these minerals and
it also helps your stomach absorb the
minerals and then lastly if you're
deficient in vitamin b1 due to stress or
too many refined carbohydrates or sugar
you're going to have not necessarily a
cramps in your calves
you're going to have tenderness in your
calves so if they're tender when you
press on them you need b1 and that would
be a nutritional yeast so you can
consume that and that just goes
completely right away so go ahead and
follow this information and I will see
you in the next video